do you want to describe your your ethnic
background so they understand
so my parents came uh my grandfather
came from cuba
back right after the revolution and um
they're definitely not white um
i'm african in cuban descent from both
um
actually some of my uh ancestors are
indigenous
to cuba and uh i don't think i have any
white at all i've never done one of
those dna tests i've never wanted to
spend money on it i don't care
because to me i've never cared about
somebody's race or religion
it's not a thing for me um and the same
thing for the proud boys we don't like
when you
join a chapter or you try to join a
chapter in the application process
we don't we don't ask those questions we
don't ask you oh well what what's your
religion
like it has like those little cards that
show you how dark your skin is
to see where you check off we don't have
that those are real
no i don't know i saw that in like one
of those guys yeah yeah okay okay
um well so so let me ask you man uh what
are the proud boys
it was it started as a joke on gavin's
show
and um gavin mcginnis gavin mcginnis
show founder of vice
co-founder co-founder of vice which i
give him crap for that
all the time um but uh
we started as a joke on gavin's show i
wasn't supposed to go past the first
uh meeting that they had he was trying
to get his intern laid
and uh he invited everybody to the bar
on a friday night and they came out and
it wasn't supposed to like he did
he made up the name from an aladdin
musical
and he did the tenets and the the the
credo
uh the degrees of membership all right
there
acapella like like straight what are
your tenants
and these are the 10 tenets of being a
proud boy and
what are the degrees and he went through
them and it was made
right there on the spot and uh it
started blowing up
and it really started to blow up after
the j-20 riots the inauguration dave
riots because we dared to fight back
you know conservatives weren't fighting
back antifa was
was uh basically burning down the city
on j-20 they were beating up trump
protesters throughout the entire
election
we saw what happened in berkeley and
there wasn't like conservatives that
that were fighting back and it wasn't
like we
they they claim us to be like some type
of security force so something that they
always say is like
oh you guys are we're doing security for
roger stone we never
we never get hired to do security for
anybody
we just went to go see stone at his
events
and we just happen to be there we've
never really provided security for
anything
so um so that's what the proud boys are
in just like the simplest terms were
a drinking club with a patriot problem
is all we are
um we don't take ourselves seriously
actually
outside of media coverage we're not a
boring crew
but we're a boring story like if you
really knew who we were on the inside
uh it's a boring story it's like it's
not newsworthy at all
so we've we've become these monsters and
last week
um we became public enemy number one for
democrats
because they refused to denounce antifa
and they had a problem they had a
problem in the polls
they knew they weren't polling right
because of that and they needed to point
a finger
they needed to find somebody and they
could have biden could have
picked so many other groups when they
were talking about white supremacy which
is
an ideology or militias which are actual
groups
you could name those but they decided he
made a critical mistake in mentioning
the proud boys
when talking about militias we're not a
militia
you know we don't train white supremacy
were not white supremacists my chapter
consists of 90
of the membership in my personal chapter
are all cubans
the minority is white
when gavin was like founding it i mean
he was saying stuff like
go i mean he was joking but he was
saying like i'm advocating was he joking
i think that's right i don't think
that's
right but he says that he was joking
and like saying i want violence go get
him go get him and then
like some people that identified as
proud boys like attacked
someone and that's where the whole
probably our violent organization came
from
uh i like i'd ask you for the context of
when we attack somebody on that
so we promise we just had the dc riot
squad
these are the daily callers reporters
who go on the ground and go to riots and
they said they filmed in
where was that was that portland or was
it was in portland that they saw proud
boys
yeah and the prop they said they said
they saw a couple proud boys really just
laying into a guy like brutally beating
him
and i said are you sure because i know
patriot prayer is up in the he said nope
these are proud boys and so these are
these are the riot crew guys these are
the people who are on the ground
covering it they work for the caller
they're not
left you know this daily caller is
founded by tucker carlson and they said
they saw
proud boys stomping some guy out um
well i haven't heard about that story in
portland but yes we have
gotten into scuffles many per se
and uh we're not afraid to defend
ourselves
but don't you going back to the first
point i was making we open the show yes
don't you think there's a problem if you
guys go to portland
and then you like you know it's an
anti-fa hotbed
understanding i understand you in the
united states you have a right to march
where you want to march
but you're jumping into the fray then
antifa is there all hot and agitated and
and crazy then they start th they come
to these events they attack you and then
you get into fights
i think i agreed with you a hundred
percent when you did the video on our
portland or
september 26 rally i agreed with you 100
it would be stupid for us to go into
downtown portland because that would
mean that we're actually looking for
problems
if we went into let's say chapman park
or uh terry shrunk plaza yes i tell you
that we're definitely looking for it
but that instance we'll talk about this
specific instance but
i took it to northern portland i put the
event on purpose i put it in the middle
of this park
that has 10 foot fences all around it's
a maze
it's impossible to get there i
communicated with pd i communicated with
fbi
they called it a state of emergency
because we were going
so there was a bigger police presence we
actually had a really good event
really safe event and we were away from
antifa and the only reason that antifa
went to there was a park
that was close by called flamingo park i
think
or peninsula park the only reason that
they went there is because
i said in a private message that i
leaked i said that we're gonna go into
peninsula park so the reason why they
were there
they were there to confront you they
were there to confront me but i knew
that it was three and a half miles away
and i knew they wouldn't have time from
beginning of this event to the end of
the event
you don't have to and a lot of people
under your feed
said uh don't uh
don't interrupt your enemy when they're
making a mistake and i i'm a hundred
percent for that
but not that good but
i decided to go over there to expose i
decided to go over there and i decided
to to dare
right to go over there and i felt the
brunt of it
i felt people were like turning on us
and like why are you going over there
and the reason why we're going over
there because the only reason why cops
did their job that week and they're
going to do their job
till the end of the year was because we
showed up
they banned cs gas i don't know if you
remember that yeah because it was
inhumane yes basically tear gas
it was inhumane to use that uh
against protesters
but the moment that we say that we're
gonna show up they lift the tear gas ban
and so tear gas is bad for humans but
it's not bad for conservatives
so they they lifted that ban on friday
and i wasn't afraid of it i was like
okay cool you you lifted the the tear
gas ban
you're not gonna use it on us
we're gonna be peaceful and we're far
away from wherever action whatever
action and
as a matter of fact don't quote me on
this i'll i'll look at this uh
statistics after this but i think they
had the most single arrests that weekend
than they had in the previous four
months
it was like 50-something arrests of
anti-voting
yes um and i categorize that as a win
but their da isn't prosecuting many of
these people they're just being cut
loose
well the cool part about it is that some
of some of those arrests were made by
uh deputized the fed's federal officers
and they were supposed to i guess the
word is undeputize them
the day after and the u.s marshals
actually refused that
so 50 portland police bureau uh cops
are going to be federally deputized by
the u.s marshals until the end of the
year
and that means anybody they arrest could
face federal charges yes so
let's go back so uh to better understand
we know the proud boys was a joke
gavin uh was he he doesn't know when to
stop i'll say that
and so he made a joke then he kept going
with it he kept pushing on it
he's had numerous videos where he's
straight-up called for violence
he was at a rally in dc where i
uh had some reporters on the ground
covering uh covering it
and i can't remember what the rally was
but it wasn't that long ago and gavin
was calling for violence
so i know that gavin stepped down from
the proud boys but that's
that's your founding this is this is a
guy who's got numerous videos
some of them are taken out of context
you know there was one video i think
where he was talking about
you know putting a choke chain on a dog
and it was taken out of context to make
it seem like he was saying attack people
but he's definitely called for violence
so i mean this is i i i believe correct
me if i'm wrong the only reason he steps
down was because he was trying to take
heat off of some proud boy members
who were facing prison time yes he
stepped down
so to touch on the first subject he
stepped down because
he needed to take heat off of this
crooked system that was prosecuting our
guys
so gavin threw a comedy show
at the metropolitan republican club and
uh
that was on a saturday and then friday
the whole place was vandalized they
broke the windows they spray painted
the entire building they put glue on the
locks and they put a threatening message
on the front door if you have
if you have gavin here you'll see what's
going to happen to you
and they went through with it so they
went through with the night
and uh my guys were walking back to
their car and
uh they were confronted by antifa they
were followed and stalked by antifa
they were confronted they threw a glass
bottle of urine at them
and then my guys fought back right
um and the cops saw this whole thing
the cops saw this this brawl
so the cops went they broke up the brawl
and they asked my guys
hey are you you guys need any medical
attention are you guys okay my guy's
like all right
we're cool and uh when he asked antifa
the guy said
f off pigs was his uh
what's what he said to the cops and
nothing happened
that's it but something was gonna happen
because it was a 2018 election
and mobs not jobs i don't know if you
remember that yep
jobs not mobs was trending and uh
they needed a boogeyman so they went
ahead and the governor of new york
governor cuomo instructed the a.g to
press
charges on the white supremacist proud
boys didn't say anything about antifa
a.g prosecuted they turned themselves in
and they knew they didn't do anything
wrong so what do you do when you know
that you didn't do anything wrong
you you take it to trial
and they took it to trial and this is
the first time
maybe i'm blind to the system but this
is the first time i ever see
that they did not get to face their
accuser
there was no victims and it's not like
the d.a didn't present victims the d.a
didn't even know
who these guys were the police didn't
know the police took the stand and was
very unbiased and
told the story and guess who was the
people that took the stand against the
proud boys
sandy bockham which is a journal
i don't even want to say journalists but
um somebody that
videotaped the whole thing and advocacy
journalism
yes advocacy so that's the people that
were put on the stand
so they got obviously they got proven
guilty
by a jury of their peers
but by a crooked system that probably
had already tainted it with all these
tweets
i think it should have been been done in
private um
the jury should have been sequestered
but that didn't happen it was an unfair
trial i mean how many how many fights
happen in new york
so the the first thing i'll say is four
years in
four years what's four years four years
in prison they're doing four years in
prison
now that that definitely seems excessive
they call it gang violence
yes so the first thing is in reference
to there being no victim
it's the state that is pressing charges
as the people the victim was the people
there's video footage of proud boys
kicking a guy on the ground in the fetal
position over and over again
so when the when the story first came
out the initial reaction we saw because
we saw
surveillance footage was antifa throw a
bottle
and then proud boys run up and start
fighting and then the proud boys
won very quickly but kept going as they
were still on the ground and that's
where they say the charges actually stem
from but actually later on
more footage was was released showing
that before
antifa even threw the bottle the proud
boys were running at them from down the
street
and then antifa threw the bottle so i
actually covered this
after after they stomped the guys on the
ground which is all on video
they they kept live streaming and one of
the guys who was streaming
was filming a couple proud boys saying
laughing about how they were stomping a
guy's head on the ground and and one guy
was like jumping
yeah i was smashing him then when when i
captured i i downloaded that stream
the proud boy when he found out that
people were i don't i think that guy
streaming wasn't a proud boy
quickly deleted it so there's video of
the charges stem from they didn't just
win like so here's the argument i was
told when i covered this people said
just because someone's gone down doesn't
mean the fight is over
and so they wanted to make sure that
antifa didn't get back up because they
were a threat but the proud boys ran
at antifa and then continued to stomp
them and then bragged about it on a live
stream afterwards
so i'm not going to tell you
that i know that exactly the entire
story on the on the video side or
anything
but when you're basically stocked
right your homes get uh
bricks thrown through the window your
tires get slashed
uh people are shot on the street uh
like when is enough like when when is it
that we say
enough protesters are protesters right
they're they have a right and i've
always said this i support
antifa's right to protest something that
they don't see that they don't see as
right
right but they're not coming to protest
they didn't come there
they didn't come there with glass
bottles of of urine
uh to to have a nice time and to not
invoke violence
and these guys are getting stalked on
the way to their to their cars
okay so i'm gonna defend them to the t
uh i don't think that
that some people understand how hard it
is like just
just being
a pb right just being a normal person
that thinks that there's something wrong
and you don't go to
to to any rallies and one day you decide
hey i'm gonna go to a comedy show with
gavin
and then there's this giant protest
outside and they arrested three antifa
members
uh i think they beat up like a
journalist and stole his camera
equipment it was actually an attendee
so i was gonna get to that too uh one of
the attendees of the club was a block
away from where
that event we were talking about to
place antifa beat and robbed him
and the i guess so there were two major
instant incidents that occurred that
night one where
did we you know i described the proud
boys run up fight the antifa win
stream it a block away a guy leaving the
the event with gavin
was attacked by antifa they stole his
backpack and fled i
think the police may have recovered the
backpack i'm not entirely sure
but uh from there there is something
really obvious we pointed out
the the the left-wing activists they
they're organized
they have advice from lawyers and they
know what they're doing you guys don't
seem to understand how the system
actually works
so my understanding of the story when i
was covering at the time
after the police came and broke up the
fight you i believe you're correct that
they ultimately didn't do much
but then came back later with charges
the proud boys cooperated entirely with
the police
gave them their information told them
what was up antifa said afu and ran off
yep so the the the my understanding is
the d.a said
if anti-fo was caught at the time and we
knew who they were they would face the
same charges but they got away
the proud boys get to go to jail do you
know what happened to those people that
that
um stole the book bag nah what happened
i don't
the d.a released him the guy stole the
book bag yes
really they let them go um
sometimes sometimes bravery is stupid
right
so sometimes being prideful is stupid
sometimes going to portland is stupid
right but like
we don't want to live in fear you know
these guys are facing the consequences
and you should
you should see the letters that they
send out uh
they're as bad as the situation that
they are in they're
they're very like
they they love this right they love this
country
they love what it stands for and they
love fighting for it
and as you said yes maybe uh things
could have worked out differently maybe
we shouldn't have talked to the cops
maybe we should have just kept our
mouths shut but would have that been the
right thing to do it's not the smartest
thing to do
i think my personal opinion i understand
what you're saying about being stalked
i've seen the videos i've been covering
for a long time i remember some of the
first events where i saw proud boys
in person confused what they were doing
at these rallies because it was this
weird you know gavin joke
but i think what you guys need to
realize is
you have scrutiny you're named by joe
biden
and that means you're walking on the
razor's edge
if antifa is surrounding your your event
and vandalizing and smashing it up you
need to let the police take care of it
and if the police won't we have a
serious problem but that needs to be the
issue that's brought up
so even donald trump has said the same
thing law enforcement needs to handle it
i understand especially in portland the
district attorneys
in portland chicago fort worth and new
york have been releasing all of these
rioters
joe biden's campaign solicited donations
to bail them out and so and kamala
harris did personally
so yeah it seems like a very serious
serious issue
what i see however is uh the american
people who are sick and tired of the
riots
the people i know in the chicagoland
area who are sick and tired of the riots
and then roll their eyes in annoyance
when they hear proud boys are coming
around and then
it's essentially just going to cause
more fighting or not that you guys are
on par with what antifa and black lives
matter are doing in rioting
but that they're sick of all of it and
they want the police to just shut it
down
so wouldn't it be better if you guys
just didn't
get into fights it would be i don't
think it would be better if you just let
cops do their jobs because cops aren't
doing their jobs they're not
it's not that they don't want to it's
that they're not allowed to so what did
it take in portland
it took two guys with an idea and a
phone call
to show up in portland for them to
finally do their job
right but there's different ways that we
can go about it it doesn't mean that
we got to fight every time that we go
somewhere because we've grown
i think we've grown a lot smarter we've
we've understand uh exactly what they're
going to do before they're going to do
it
and we show up in portland we're far as
hell from everything
and they finally get a rest they finally
get to use their cs gas they were happy
they were happy that they got these
tools that were necessary to do their
job
but so if we let if we let police
officers and we
we say oh well we're going to leave
everything to the police officers
well we've left everything to the police
officers in these cities and they
continue to burn
but kenosha happened i'm sorry kenosha
happened because of portland
dc happened because of portland uh
chicago is happening new york i could
keep going atlanta
uh austin like portland is setting an
example for this and these guys think
that they can get away with it i'm not
saying that we're we're
some vigilantes that are going to fix
everything and we let the police do
their job when we went to portland
we've let the police do their job every
time that i've been to portland the two
last times that i've been to portland
we've let the cops do their job we just
show up
so first it was good to see there was no
violence and the way you handled going
to portland i understand makes sense
yes you got a state of emergency
declared the police powers were restored
but the police have been making these
arrests
the first deputization came from oregon
state police
because every time they arrest these
black lives matter or anti-variety
it's the district attorney who keeps
releasing them the state police actually
issued a statement saying
what's the point of i'm paraphrasing by
the way what's the point of doing this
if everyone everyone we arrest is cut
loose immediately and come right back
out in riot
so i understand what you're saying you
you the peace the police were empowered
a little bit more
there was a deputization of local police
which
which which will retain and there
actually is a breaking story right now
that the d.a i believe his name is mike
schmidt in portland cut
loose an anti-for writer and the feds
immediately came in and issued federal
charges
correct there was a statement made by so
so that is one
i guess you there's there's pros and
there's cons to that result
you know that the increasing authority
of the federal government is is worrying
in my opinion
if local district attorneys aren't
stopping these people we have now 130
plus days of rioting
it becomes really really difficult to
figure out how to solve this problem so
i guess there was in terms of a law
enforcement result
you got one there was no violence so i
can respect that i was wrong
about they're gonna you know i i said
it's gonna be violence people are gonna
i'm worried about it and
it didn't turn out that way so well you
were right you were right in your video
well what i mean what i mean to say is
yes i believe my criticism was correct
yeah
the potential for violence is great but
i was wrong in that i absolutely thought
there was going to be clashes and
violence we've seen the videos
and i think the american people are
tired and i fully understand what you're
saying
and there there really is a serious
challenge in that we have all of these
cities
where rioting has kept popping up
notably in the pacific northwest but
it's it's happened in new york
and we just had la lakers riots i guess
in l.a which was absurd
in in portland they just tore down a
statue of abraham lincoln
now the teddy roosevelt one it was
indigenous people's day okay i
understand they're mad about both of
these individuals
but it doesn't seem like there's a
cohesive group it seems like you have
emboldened groups far left extremists
who have been riding now for
several months of varying ideologies
from antifa to indigenous rights to
black lives matter
you've got the indigenous activists
tearing down abraham lincoln and you'd
think that would be something the black
lives matter people actually wouldn't
want torn down
you've got some fringe leftists tearing
down frederick douglass in rochester
which is insane and you think you
wouldn't want torn down
but anyway ultimately i think while i i
certainly believe
you know trump is correct when he says
it's coming from the left the way i
described it before is
if 300 proud boys were marching you know
in front of my house
i just be like what are you what are you
doing you know like why i don't get it
if 300 auntie people were marching in my
house i'd be calling the police
and saying you need to get down here
because these are the people that put on
masks smash things
we recently saw in uh in denver
there was a security guard hired by a
news outlet nine news
and he shot a trump supporter according
to a reporter on scene
he came up behind her and approached a
trump supporter police uh
supporter and made some kind of move
towards him
the trump supporter slapped him in in
apparently some kind of
preemptive or defensive measure knocking
his head off
he took two steps back and the guy was
pulling his gun out as he was stepping
back and shot him in the face
as the dude was letting off some spray
we also saw what happened
in portland with michael reinel stalking
some trump supporters
and then calling them out we got a
couple right here take it out here yeah
and then he shoots them twice in the
chest
we're not seeing uh so
where where are the like trump
supporting conservatives that are doing
that kind of behavior showing up to
rallies put on by the left
attacking people hospitalizing them like
i mentioned
we do have the example of from the dc
right squad
of i believe it was portland where proud
boys were beating somebody up
so there are you know there are problems
here
but we tend to see the way i describe it
is on the left you have a
wide spread of blunt force
whereas extremists associated with the
right whatever that really means
it's complicated terminology you have
extremist actions that are extremely
elevated in terms of you know mass
shootings and things like that and
bombings
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you